i just have to start by saying i loved
the two of you together in this movie it
is so fun and spooky and sexy and i feel
like it's kind of everything you want
out of like a modern gothic tale i would
love to ask how the two of you kind of
joined the project natalie evie is
someone who feels like a breath of fresh
air in this movie you know she's a
modern heroine who gets kind of dropped
into a different time with different
traditions i would say is probably the
right way of putting it um what
initially drew you to the part yeah i
loved the kind of um
yeah the clash of those kind of two
worlds you know she's a very modern
woman
um but i just i really was drawn to
the idea of
in a way like this feminist sort of
re-telling of a dracula story which is
obviously a very old very well-known
um story and uh and what would happen if
you placed someone very very modern in
that context like it's immediately just
like really interesting and for all the
reasons um but you know as a
creative myself like i kind of
was drawn to evie's sort of artist
struggle and you know like um
that sort of curiosity as well about
family history you know um
and the sort of
not so great parts of it but also
they're just a part of your
your your story and um you know and this
is like worst case scenario
what happens when you find out um so i
just was immediately just drawn to the
characters like
handling of that but also just the sort
of context is just a lot of fun
as well thomas walter has a lot of
layers as a character i don't think
that's an over exaggeration um and we
get to see those gradually peel back
over the course of this movie
so what were you most excited to get i
get to dig into and explore in him
um i think it's really fun to like
i love just playing characters i love
the extremities of
human
behavior and the possibilities and
one thing that i love is that i feel
like we all do possess the
capability or the capacity to be
sociopathic or
enlightened insanely um
and a lot of that's determined by
environment
so i do have a lot of empathy for human
beings generally
uh i think there's a lot of conditioning
and i mean there's
although walter is absolutely insane and
evil
and
i think it is important still to find
that empathy
in that character
um
[Music]
doesn't excuse any responsibility but
definitely to find to find that the
human humanity in that and so i guess
just toying with that playing with that
and having
it was almost like i was
doing a film and i got to play two
different characters which was fun
um
and the one thing that i did a lot with
when i was playing
good walter
i like was clenching my jaw a lot
and that was one way of
the bad walter kind of
being
held back
so that was like a little
nod to bad walter in there but yeah i
know it was really good fun i enjoyed it
a
lot
i'm glad that you brought up kind of
he feels like two different characters
in the sense that i think you both get
to play the romance of their
relationship before the horror starts
like it's a very clear delineation
between the two which i thought was
really fascinating um and i guess this
is for both of you what did you try to
focus on in terms of how your
character's relationship changes and
evolves to kind of embrace that darker
side later in the movie i think well
jess um was so good at kind of helping
us build intimacy
um from the beginning and i think what's
so what uh thomas was saying about the
humanity of walt you know he's a very
expert kind of charmer you know
manipulator and he and i think that he
can see
evie's real vulnerability and like
you know needing to be the sort of
savior in a way and he becomes exactly
that like from the beginning when he
kind of defends her against um
uh
uh sean pat patrick's character and it's
like
um
[Music]
so she's immediately just kind of
enamored with him because he is the
powerful man and he's like
kind of come in and sort of
been cool with her like sort of been
done the right thing and so he kind of
becomes this what she needs him to be
and um i just and i think that very
quickly that builds intimacy with them
and as she's becoming more and more
unsure of herself i'm sure of you know
her instincts and believing her
instincts like he just very very
expertly just makes sure that he is
there to kind of like
push the narrative or push the the the
events in the direction that he needs
and it's almost so subtle and
not
not kind of apparent until
the very last moment it's almost like
the penny drops and it's like too late
to even
get out so yeah
it
it really was i think building that
intimacy with us from the beginning was
like hugely important because you're
just more likely to trust that person
that you feel close to in an environment
as well where she knew nobody
um and but she feels closest to him and
i think that was something that he
completely manipulates and
yeah exploits
there are some genuinely terrifying
moments in this movie but i would say
the dinner scene is probably the most
unsettling for the reason that you
mentioned natalie which is the penny
drops right this is kind of like the big
moment um how much preparation did the
two of you do for that scene in terms of
rehearsal was there anything that you
kind of really wanted to come through
um you know because it feels like such a
pivotal scene that really hinges on a
lot of big reveals and kind of truths
coming to the forefront yeah for sure
i think
i
was really didn't want to play
the
the
bad guy all of a sudden try to get a
balance of that i think there's
something really eerie about
someone just acting as a nonchalantly as
if it's like yeah and this is what it is
and stuff which i really loved and
natalie's performance really
complemented that for me her like
sheer panic and terror
i always felt for you because you had to
do that so many times
that emotional like oh my god and she
killed it well
interestingly the day that we shot that
scene or where like most of the kind of
performance happened my mum was visiting
me on set
and the door
in which i was banging against trying to
get out my mum was actually set up in a
little
had a little sort of monitor and
headphones watching
and she was on the other side of that
door
and it was amazing how useful that was
and usually like having kind of your
loved ones on set isn't doesn't
necessarily isn't isn't always like
conducive to like
good performance because it takes you
out with the character that you're doing
but there was something about being like
i need to get to the other side of the
store and get to my mom was really like
like it just someone it was like they'd
lock the door they had someone sort of
standing behind it and it was almost
like just using that like i need to get
to the person that i love or get out of
here to get to that person was like
really useful and i remember just
feeling like devastated like
absolutely devastated and panicked and
terrified and um
yeah like that day that we did that my
mom was literally on the other side
and i was a bit like mommy all right
after she was like yeah i don't didn't
like that didn't like you
screaming like that um
but yeah like i think um that scene
particularly is like
she's suddenly confronted with the
complete like
lack of empathy the complete coldness of
these people
and she
um
is like the the realization that she has
to fight for herself
um because everyone here is like just
dark and bad and
yeah just everything bad
um
but yeah i mean from the second she
walks in and sees all these masks and
doing all these like kind of cult like
hand gestures at each other i mean
yeah it was it was a yeah it's not good
i think
yeah the finished product speaks for
itself for sure um thank you both so
much for taking the time to talk to me
about this movie it is so spooky and
sexy and fun and i cannot wait for
everyone else to get to see it too so
thank you
thank you
have a good day lovely speaking to you
you